a buddy here at work forwarded me an
email uh an article the other day
and this is just
this is just something i want to just
put out into the universe here
japan this is a february 22nd article
we'll link to it in the show notes here
japan appointed a minister of loneliness
after seeing suicide rates in the
country increase for the first time in
11 years
if you look at the suicide rates of
what's going on in the country right now
after a year of people being stuck by
themselves and isolated
um usually we lag you know four to
four to six months three to six months
behind some of these other countries
who are ahead of us
man i
we are talking about more people in
october 2020 committed suicide than died
by covid
in japan there were 2153 suicide
deaths that month and 1765 deaths
a major group that this is impacting
which is a statistical anomaly doesn't
happen in this way
usually it's men who complete suicide
there is a 70
increase year over year of women who
have died by suicide
women are lonely and exhausted
and more and more single women live
alone in japan many of them don't have
stable employment
they are trying to figure out what's
next
they have to support their own lives
they don't have permanent jobs
and then something like this shows up
here's what i want to tell you
it's yet another another statistical
proof another
country trying to figure out how to deal
with this absolute
monster that has pervaded our cultures
across the globe for years and that is
this monster of loneliness
the pull you're up by your bootstraps
thing is a lie
it's not real it's fake it's a myth i
don't care how tough you
are i don't care how much money you make
i don't care how high up the mountain
you think you're going to climb someday
it is not real it's not real
you gotta have other people in your life
you have to and i know kovit makes that
so hard
please reach out to people and please
please please
if you're gonna hurt yourself call
somebody let them know
call somebody let them know make one
call make two calls make three calls
there's text hotlines now we're gonna
link to the
us hotline here in the show notes
you matter to somebody you matter to me
if you get to the point you think your
life isn't worth anymore
make a call reach out to somebody
even if somebody i've talked to in 5
years 10 years 15 years even it's to a
neighbor
knock on somebody's door make that call
don't do life alone don't do life alone